what's your story what uh from childhood
what are some fun memories you have fond
memories where did you grow up
well I don't give away that information
in the United States yeah yeah yeah in
Virginia yeah what are some rough
moments what are some beautiful moments
that you remember
I I had a very good family growing up
um the the like rough moment and I'll
tell you a story that just happened to
me two days ago and it [ __ ] me up man
it really didn't you'll be the first
I've never told that I tried to tell my
wife this two nights ago and I couldn't
get it out so my father uh he's a
disabled veteraner he was a disabled
veteran he was in the Army and got hurt
and I was in a wheelchair his whole life
um for all my growing up
he uh
he was my biggest fan he just wanted to
know everything about you know what's
going on in the FBI my stories
um I was a local cop before the FBI and
I got to a high-speed car chase uh you
know foot chase and all that and kicking
doors and he he wanted to hear no other
stories and at some points I was kind of
too cool for school and ah Dad I just
want to break and all that and things
going on uh we we lost my dad during
covid
um not because of Kobe but it was around
that time but but it was right when
cover was kicking off and so he died in
a hospital by himself and I didn't get
to see him then
um and then uh my mom had some people
visiting her the other night and uh Tom
and Karen rogenberg and I'll say they're
my second biggest fans right behind my
dad
um they they always asking about me and
in my career and they've read the books
and seen the movie they'll even tell you
that Silk Road movie was good
[Laughter]
on that but and so they came over and uh
and I helped them with something and uh
my mom was that called me back a couple
days later and she said I appreciate you
helping them you know I know you know
fixing someone's Apple phone over the
phone really isn't what you do for a
living it's not it's kind of beneathy
and all that and uh but but I appreciate
it uh and she said oh they they loved
hearing the stories about you know Silk
Road and all those things and she goes
you know your dad he loved those stories
he just he I just wish he could have
heard him like he even would tell me he
would say uh you know maybe maybe Chris
will come home and uh I'll get him drunk
and he'll tell me the stories
um but and then she goes maybe one day
in heaven you can tell them those
stories and I [ __ ] lost it I literally
stood in my shower sobbing yeah like
like a child like it just thinking about
like all my dad wanted was those stories
yeah
and now I'm on a [ __ ] podcast telling
the stories to the world and yeah and I
did tell them yeah so
did you ever have like a long heart to
heart with him about like
about such stories he was in the
hospital one time and I went through and
uh I want to know about his history like
his life what he did and I think he may
be sensationalize some of it but that's
what you want your dad's a hero so you
want to hear those things it's a good
Storyteller
um yeah again I don't know what was true
and not true but you know
some of it was really good
um and it was just good to hear his life
but you know we lost him and and now
those stories are gone
you miss him yeah
what did he teach you about what it
means to be a man
so my dad
um
he was an engineer and so part of his
job we worked for Vermont
Power and electric or whatever it was I
mean he when he first got married to my
mom and all that um like he flew around
a helicopter I'll check out like power
lines and dancing he would he used to
swim inside to scuba into dams to check
to make sure that they were functioning
properly and all that pretty cool [ __ ]
yeah
and then he couldn't walk anymore
I probably would have killed myself if
my life switched like that so bad and my
dad probably went through some dark
points but he had that from me maybe
um and so to get through that struggle
to teach me like you know you you press
on you have a family people count on you
you do what you got to do
um that was that was big
yeah
I'm sure you make him proud man I I I'm
sure I do but
I don't think he knew that that I knew
that
well you get to pass on that love to
your kids now I try I try but I I can't
impress them as much as uh my dad
impressed me
I can try all I want but